hey everyone
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
i'm sure you must have watched our
previous videos on angular if you
haven't watched them already i suggest
you go through them
for easy tutorials on various topics on
angular
now angular developers are in demand and
i'm sure you need help
in cracking your next interview so in
this video i present to you some
commonly asked angular interview
questions
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure you hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
now let's begin i've classified the
questions into two sections
one is the beginner level questions and
one is the advanced level questions
so now let's begin with beginner level
questions
starting with the most basic what
exactly is angular
now angular is an open source javascript
front-end framework
which is completely written in
typescript this framework brings
structure and consistency to web
applications
and provides excellent scalability and
maintainability
now it's primarily aimed to develop
single page applications
and is maintained by google it uses html
syntax to express your application's
components clearly
it is designed for web desktop and
mobile platforms
next up is what exactly is typescript
now typescript is a superset of
javascript
that offers excellent consistency it is
highly recommended as it provides
some syntactic sugar and makes the code
base more comfortable to understand
and maintain ultimately typescript code
compiles down to javascript
that can run efficiently in any
environment
now typically typescript is installed as
an npm package
and thus can be installed with the
following command that is npm install
hyphen g
typescript moving on to our third
question
what exactly is data binding and which
type of data binding does
angular deploy now data binding is a
phenomenon that allows
any internet user to manipulate web page
elements
now it generally uses dynamic html and
does not require
any complex scripting or programming
we use data binding in pages that
contain interactive components such as
forms calculators tutorials and games
data binding makes incremental display
of a web page more convenient
when it comes to angular it uses the
two-way data binding
any changes made to the user interface
are reflected in the corresponding model
state
conversely any changes in the model
state are reflected in the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
next question what are single page
applications
now single page applications are web
applications
that load just once with new features
just being mere additions to the user
interface
it does not load new html pages
to display the content instead it's
generated dynamically
this is made possible through
javascript's ability to manipulate the
dom elements on the existing page itself
an spa approach is faster thus providing
a seamless user experience
differentiate between angular and
angularjs
now here's a simple table for you so
here are the features that we're going
to
differentiate the two on the basis of
first is language angularjs uses
javascript while angular
uses typescript when it comes to
architecture
angularjs supports the model view
controller design
when angular uses components and
directives
angularjs is not supported by mobile
browsers
while angular supports all mobile
browsers
angularjs does not support dependency
injection while angular does
when it comes to routing at route
provider is used to provide routing
information in the case of angularjs
and in case of angular at route
configuration is used to define routing
information
when it comes to management angularjs is
difficult to manage with an increase in
source code size
while angular is better structured easy
to create
and can manage bigger applications
next up what are decorators in angular
decorators are a design pattern or
functions that define how
angular features work now they are used
to make
prior modifications to a class service
or
filter angular supports four types of
decorators
namely class decorators property
decorators
method decorators and parameter
decorators
next question mention some advantages of
angular
first up is custom components now
angular enables users
to build their own components that can
pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
this is achieved with the help of these
components
data binding as discussed earlier
angular enables users to effortlessly
move data from javascript code
to the view and react to users events
without having to write any code
manually angular supports dependency
injection
which enables users to write modular
services
and inject them wherever they need it
when it comes to testing tests are
first-class tools and
angular has been built from ground up
with testability in mind
you will have the ability to test every
part of your application
and that is highly recommended
next up is comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing with your application and more
lastly angular is cross-platform and
compatible
with multiple browsers an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers be it chrome
firefox safari and operating systems
like windows mac os
and linux what's new with angular 10
first up is that older versions of
typescript
are not supported previous versions of
angular supported
typescript 3.6 3.7 and even 3.8
but with angular 10 typescript bumped to
typescript 3.9
warnings about common js imports now
logging
of unknown property bindings or element
names
in templates is increased to the error
level which was previously a warning
angular now supports an optional strict
setting which offers a stricter project
setup when you create a new workspace
there's an addition of ngcc features
with a program-based entry point finder
there are common compiler updates and
updated url routing
angular 10 has several deprecated apis
that were previously redundant
with angular 10 version there have been
a number of bug fixes
important ones being the compiler
avoiding undefined expressions
and the core avoiding a migration error
new default browser configuration
browser configuration for new projects
has been upgraded to outdo older and
less used browsers
next up is core all the warnings will be
now logged in
as errors next update is converting
pre-iv code
now all the pre-iv dependencies from npm
should be transformed to iv dependencies
which is supposed to take place as a
precursor to running
ngtsc at the application
and lastly we have service workers for
the service worker
a fix has been put in for a situation in
which there was a chance
that the service worker would not
register when there is a long running
task
or a recurring timeout
next up is what are templates in angular
now angular templates are written with
html
that contains angular specific elements
and attributes
now in combination with model and
controllers information
these templates can be rendered to
provide a dynamic view to the user
now templates are a very predominant
feature of angular
that describe how information can be
displayed in the view
next question is what are annotations in
angular
now these annotations are used to create
an annotation array
they are basically the metadata set on
the class that is used to reflect the
metadata library
what are directives in angular
directives are attributes
that allow the user to write new html
syntax
specific to their applications now these
execute whenever the angular compiler
finds them in the dom
now again angular supports three
different types of directives
there are component directives attribute
directives and structural directives
next up what is aot compilation and what
are some of its advantages
now aots that stands for ahead of time
compiler
basically converts the angular html and
typescript
into javascript code during the build
phase
that is before the browser downloads and
runs the code
so basically all the html and typescript
code
is converted to javascript during the
build phase which means no additional
time is spent on converting it into
javascript later during the run phase
right so when it comes to advantages of
course there's faster rendering
there are fewer asynchronous requests it
has smaller angular framework download
size
there's quick detection of errors and
this also offers better security
moving on to the next question what are
components
now components are the most basic
building blocks
of the ui in an angular application now
every component is associated with a
template
and is a subset of directives only one
component can be instantiated
per element in a template now an angular
application typically consists of a root
component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
now every component is decorated with
the help of add component decorator
which provides additional information
and component must belong to the ng
module
lastly components implement something
called the life cycle hooks
you will learn about them a little later
in the video
next up what are pipes in angular
now pipes are simple functions that are
designed to accept
a particular input value process this
value
and return an output which is a
transformed value
now angular supports several built-in
pipes
however you can also create custom pipes
that cater to your needs
but to speak about a few saline features
pipes are defined using the pipe symbol
pipes can be chained with other pipes
and pipes can be provided
with arguments by using the coal enzyme
next up
what are pure pipes now these pipes
are pipes that use pure functions
as a result of this a pure pipe doesn't
use
any internal state and the output
remains the same as long as the
parameters
passed stay the same angular calls a
pure pipe
only when it detects a change in the
parameters being passed
now a single instance of a pure pipe is
used throughout all components
next up what are impure pipes
now for every change detection cycle in
angular
these impure pipes are called regardless
of the change in the input fields
as long as there's a change detected
these pipes are called
as a result multiple pipe instances are
created for these pipes
now inputs passed to these pipes can
also be mutable
by default all pipes are pure however
you can also
mention impure pipes using the pure
property
now here's a code for specifying impure
pipes
you can use the pure property and either
mention true or false
true meaning it's a pure pipe and false
indicates that it's an impure pipe
next up what is the pipe transform
interface
now as the name suggests the interface
receives an input value
and transforms it into the desired
format with a transform method
it is typically used to implement custom
pipes
now here's again a small piece of code
now you can see that the pipe transform
interface is being used
which in turn executes the transform
method now this transform method is the
one that is responsible to
change your input and give a transformed
output
moving on what is ng module
now ng modules are basically containers
that reserve a block of code to an
application domain
or a workflow now the at ng module
takes a metadata object that describes
how to compile a components template
and generate an injector at runtime in
addition to this
ng module also identifies the modules
components
detectives services pipes and also
ensures
that it makes them public so that
external components can use them
all of this is taken care of by the ng
module
next up what are filters in angular
now filters are used to format an
expression
and present it to the user they can be
used in
view templates controllers or services
now to name a few there's
date filter which formats a date to a
specified format
there's filter filter that selects a
subset of items from an array
there's the json filter which formats an
object
to a json string there's limit 2 which
limits an array or a string into a
specified number of elements or
characters
then there's lowercase which formats a
string to lowercase
and so on moving on to the next question
what is view encapsulation in angular
now view encapsulation basically defines
whether the template and styles defined
within the component
can affect the application or vice versa
angular provides three encapsulation
strategies
there's emulated encapsulation which
means that the styles from the main html
propagate to the component then there is
native
which indicates that the styles from the
main html do not propagated the
component
meaning it does not affect the component
and lastly there is none
which means that styles from the
component propagate back to the
main html and therefore are visible to
all the components on the page
now this indicates any different types
of changes and how it is affecting the
entire application
moving on what are controllers now
as the name suggests controllers control
the data of angular applications
they are regular javascript objects and
the ng controller directive defines the
application controller
next question what do you understand by
scope in angular
now the scope in angular binds the html
that is basically the view and the
javascript that is the controller
it is also an object with the available
properties and methods required for your
application
now when you make a controller in
angular you pass the dollar scope object
as an argument moving on to the most
commonly asked question
explain the life cycle hooks in angular
as discussed earlier every component in
angular has a life cycle
angular creates and renders these
components and also destroys them
before removing them from the document
object model
it is achieved with the help of these
life cycle hooks
now let's have a look at them first up
is ng on changes
now this responds when angular sets or
resets
data bound input properties
ng on it is a hook that initializes
the directive or a component after
angular first displays
the data bound properties and sets the
components
input properties ng do check
detects and acts upon the changes that
angular can't
or won't detect on its own
ng after content init responds after
ng projects external content into the
components view
ng after content checked response after
angular checks the content
projected into the component
ng after in it responds after angular
initializes
the components views and child views
ng after view checked responds after
angular checks the components views and
the child views
lastly there's ng on destroy which
cleans up
just before angular destroys the
directive or the component
moving on to the next question what is
string interpolation
in angular now string interpolation
is a one-way data binding technique that
is used by angular
now it outputs the data from typescript
code to html view
it is typically denoted with the help of
curly braces
and it helps display data from the
component to the view
to help you understand it's working i've
created a variable called name
here in my app.component.ts file
and initialize it to simplylon and back
in my html file
i've created a heading tag
a header tag which displays the name of
the company is
and i've interpolated here with the help
of double curly braces
so when i run the file the output looks
something like this
the name of the company is simply learn
so this is how string interpolation is
achieved
in angular moving on to next question
what are template statements
template statements are properties or
methods used in html
for responding to user events now with
these template statements
the application that you create or
you're working on
can have the capability to engage users
through actions such as submitting forms
or displaying dynamic content
most common example is the button tag
the template here is delete hero this
method is called when the user clicks on
the button
so this brings interactivity to your
application
with that we come to the end of the
first section which included the
beginner level questions
moving on let's look at some advanced
level questions
what is the difference between ahead of
time and just in time compilation
now ahead of time compilation converts
your code during the build time
before the browser downloads and runs
the code
in case of just in time compilation this
process is a way of compiling computer
code
to machine code during the execution
phase
aot ensures faster rendering to the
browser
while just in time is basically a
dynamic compilation
in case of ahead of time compiling the
user should include the
hyphen hyphen aot option with the ng
build or ng serve command
and jit compilation is the default
compilation when you run the ng build or
ng
serve cli commands
next up explain the add component
decorator
now here's a simple screenshot of what
that component
decorator encompasses is it is basically
a typescript class
that is used to create components
this genre of class is then decorated
with the add component decorator
the decorators purpose is to accept a
metadata
object that provides relevant
information about
the component now the image above shows
an app component
which is a pure typescript class
decorated with that component decorator
the object
that gets accepted by the decorator
provides properties like
template url selectors style urls
and many more now here the template url
property
points to an html file defining what you
see
on the application moving ahead
what are services in angular angular
services
perform tasks that are used by multiple
components
now these tasks could be data fetching
network connections
or database management among others they
perform
all the operational tasks for the
components and avoid
rewriting of code a service can be
written once and then injected into all
the components that use it
generally components are used to only
display information on the ui
they do not perform any other back-end
tasks
to perform tasks like validating
information
or network connections etc you can make
use of a service
one advantage is that this service can
be injected into multiple components
that make use of the same piece of code
with this you can avoid redundancy
moving on
what are promises and observables now
while both the components deal with
asynchronous events in angular
promises handle one such event at a time
while observables handle a sequence of
events over
some time so to give you a brief
explanation promises emit a single value
at a time
while observables are only executed when
subscribed to them using the subscribe
method now promises also execute
immediately after they're created
and they're not cancelable while
observables help perform operations like
for each
filter retry etc promises
push errors to the child promises and
observables can be unsubscribed to
so that the listener stops receiving
further values
next up what is ng on init and how is it
defined
now again here's a small snippet of code
ng on init is a life cycle hook as we
discussed earlier and there is a
callback method that is run by angular
to indicate that a component has been
created
it takes no parameters and returns a
void type
so i'm sure you can see here in the code
it takes no parameters and returns a
void
next up explain the use of ng4 in a tag
or explain the ng4 directive
now the ng for directive is basically
like a for loop it is used to build
lists and tables and html templates so
in
simple terms this directive is used to
iterate over an array
or an object and create template for
each such element
now in the snippet you can see there is
let items in
item list and then i have string
interpolated the
uh variable item so let item here
creates a local variable that will be
available inside the template
of items indicates that we are iterating
over the items iterable
and the asterisk before ng4 creates a
parent template
next up what are template and reactive
forms so there are two different methods
to create forms
we have the template driven approach and
we have the reactive form approach
so let's have a look at them in case of
template driven approach
the conventional form tag is used to
create forms
angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object
representation for this tag controls can
be added to the form using the
ng model tag multiple controls can be
grouped using the ng control group
module
now a form value can be generated using
the form dot value object
and form data as exported as json values
basic html validations can be used to
validate the form fields
in the case of custom validations
directives can be used
when it comes to reactive forms this
approach
basically revolves around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactor forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
the active forms are code driven unlike
template driven approach
reactive forms break the traditional
declarative approach
and eliminate the anti-pattern of
updating data via the two-way data
binding method
typically reactive form control creation
is synchronous
and can be unit tested with synchronous
programming techniques
moving on what is bootstrap how is it
added to angular
now bootstrap is a powerful toolkit it
is a collection of basic html css and
javascript tools
for creating and building responsive web
applications
there are two ways to embed bootstrap
libraries
first up is using the bootstrap cdn
which is the content delivery network
now this enables users to load the css
and javascript
files remotely from its servers
the other way is to use angular
bootstrap via npm
now this is used to add bootstrap to
your angular project
by installing it into your project
folder
now you can use commands like npm
install bootstrap
and npm install jquery to install them
for your project
if you wish to learn bootstrap in detail
i highly suggest you check out our video
on angular bootstrap
the tutorial explains how to embed
bootstrap and use it to create and good
looking angular applications
what is eager and lazy loading
eager loading is the default module
loading strategy
now all the feature modules under eager
loading are loaded before your
application even starts
this is typically used for small size
applications since lesser
modules are used all of these modules
are loaded initially which makes
running of these kind of applications
extremely fast
when it comes to lazy loading all the
loading happens dynamically
all feature modules are loaded on demand
it is used for bigger applications where
the modules are not required at the
start of applications
this makes the application faster since
no time is spent on loading unnecessary
modules
next up what type of dom does angular
implement
dom or document object model treats an
xml
or html document as a tree structure
in which each node is an object
representing a part of the document
now angular uses the regular dom this
updates the entire tree structure
of html tags until it reaches the data
that has to be updated
now to ensure that the speed and
performance are not affected
angular implements something called as a
change detection
next up how is dependency injection
achieved in angular now dependencies
are objects or services that a component
needs to perform functions
correct now with the help of dependency
injection
these classes can request dependencies
from external sources
rather than creating them on their own
here i've created a service
called demo service using the command
ngg service demo service
and i've also added a small snippet of
code when
you create that service
now these services can be injected to
your
main component and perform various
functions
next up how does angular routing work
now i'm sure you must have observed that
the url changes
every time you click on your user
interface on an application correct
every time you navigate through the
application or move from one page to
another
the url changes now this means
that the application is being routed or
you're navigating through the
application
so basically routing helps navigate
through a web application
especially in case of single page
applications now as discussed
earlier single-page applications are
loaded just once
so any new content that is being
displayed is just a mere addition it's
not being loaded again
so routing plays a vital role in case of
single page applications
typically it is specified with the help
of the forward slash
and followed by a path that defines a
new content
now i'm just taking the same example
that i took before
this was the example for string
interpolation however you can see that
we have a navigation bar here
with four different options for that is
home about services and login
and for home and login i've created a
path
and added routing to it so when i click
on the home icon
you can see that some content is being
displayed onto the screen
and if you observe you can see that
there is a forward slash
with the path name home here which
indicates that routing has occurred
same with login when i click on it the
path changes
and the login page appears if you wish
to learn
the concept of routing i suggest you
check out a video
the tutorial explains routing in detail
moving on what are form control and form
groups
now a form control is basically a class
that enables
validation for each input field
an instance of this class is created
and these instances help check the
values of the field
and see if they are touched untouched
dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so for every
field
in the form the data that is being
provided is validated with the help of
these controls
if it is dirty it means that the value
has been changed
if the data provided holds good for a
particular condition
then the control is said to be valid and
so on
with the help of these controls you can
determine if the value provided is
legitimate or not
this can be achieved with the help of
form control
when it comes to form group when the
form group class
represents a group of controls now a
form
can have multiple control groups the
form
group class returns true if all the
controls are valid
and also provides validation errors if
any
next up is how is testing achieved in
angular
now angular uses jasmine to run various
tests
the jasmine framework allows various
functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
the task runner for these tests is
typically
karma and karma uses a configuration
file
to set the startup reporters and the
testing framework
next question is what is package.json
now npm installs package.json when a new
workspace is created
now this file includes a starter set of
packages
some of which are required by angular
now typically
it's organized into two groups one is
dependencies
these are essential to run your
applications and we have
dev dependencies these are essential to
develop applications
so with that we come to the end of this
session
i hope these interview questions help
you crack your next interview
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here